le naturisme a aussi sa journée mondiale
et à villette-d'anthon des plus anciens
clubs de la région s'est senti beaucoup
plus proche de la nature grâce il est
vrai au soleil flambant neuf de ce
printemps qui commence vraiment en
reportage dans le plus simple appareil
d'olivier thiêt et georges adel
fondée en 1963
le club de la reynière est aujourd'hui
le plus grand centre de naturisme du sud
est de la france
chaque week end 600 membres actifs se
retrouvent ici au bord de la piscine ou
sur les courts de tennis
loin du stress des voyeurs et des tabous
une clientèle familiale pour laquelle le
naturisme est un loisir comme les autres
autrefois il y avait un respect de la
vie végétarienne on évitait la viande on
évite l alcool on héritait beaucoup de
choses comme cela
aujourd'hui c'est plus possible parce
que les jeunes recrues disant nous qui
très vite si on appliquait ce régime qui
peut paraître bon certains anciens mais
aujourd'hui dépassé dépassé en effet
aujourd'hui le discours des naturistes
est plus proche de celui des gentils
membres du club méditerranée que de la
doctrine sunnite et sportives des pères
fondateurs allemand pour vous le
naturisme c'est une philosophie
pour nager en synthèse on est nature
décontractée c'est très bien on est bien
il ya la piscine lé tennis ont néanmoins
la brute tout le monde c'est petit
paradis terrestre en est bien là c'est
pour ça un paradis terrestre qui ne fait
plus vraiment recette pour cette journée
portes ouvertes seule une trentaine de
visiteurs se sont présentés et pas
seulement à cause de la fête des mères à
régnèrent comme dans les autres clubs
le nombre d'adhérents est en baisse
depuis quelques années aujourd'hui le
naturisme est à la recherche d'une
nouvelle jeunesse
[Applaudissements]